Lawlor Oh dinosaur or wait tom is that
you
and weren't you in Tokyo just last week
yes which is why I'm here to share my
excitement of Japan it's classic movies
awesome can't wait for the sequel maybe
you'll be the dinosaur and I'll be the
scientist dr. Wong now what are you
gonna be demoing today well today I'm
going to be demoing a custom machine
learning API that leverages Google's ml
api's vision speech translation and
natural language but don't worry I could
turn into a crazy chemical monster like
me it's gonna be an easily a degradable
solution sweet let's jump right into it
all right so what you're seeing here on
the left side is a video stream this is
actually using something called WebRTC
which is a real-time communication API
released by Google and it pretty much
allows you to use the webcam in your
computer and in your web browser so we
use those feats actually drive for
different API s and the first one that
you actually sees the vision API so two
features that come out that come out of
the vision API are phases and labels now
with phases what we're actually using
the we're trying to figure out the
emotional state out of your face so if
we smile you're gonna see that it says
Joy's very likely so that's it provides
cool insight into the kind of your
emotional state of individuals that you
find within an image another cool
feature is labels so labels pretty much
identify different things are found
within the image so in our case you know
there's there's a forehead or socialite
different smile exactly right so you can
use this to help identify different
things you may find within an image so
moving on to the next API which is a
speech API what we actually did here was
it's we're using the streaming speech
API and we took the audio stream from
the WebRTC video feed and fed it through
a through a WebSocket to our compute
engine instance in the backend and with
that what we can do is transcribe text
in a relative real-time so what that
does is kind of it pretty much opens up
the door to the other api's that are
available through Google so for example
maybe you want to do translation
maybe it's you're speaking to somebody
in a different language so I was just in
Japan what if you needed to talk to
somebody in Japanese so with the speech
API and Translate you're able to do this
in a relative real-time pretty cool
right yeah so once you get into text
then you can use that as input for
translation and NLP right exactly
now NLP natural language as I said
identifies different objects
within your statement and figures out
what the what kind of sentiment do you
have around that so like let's say for
instance I'm Godzilla I love Google
cloud platform you'll see that down on
the bottom here there's a whole bunch of
different objects that I've found
important within that statement the
importance of those doctor of those
objects as well as kind of how you're
feeling about it awesome now we can tell
just how much people love Godzilla and
Google cloud platform Wow Tom for a
terrorizing dinosaur that was pretty
awesome
yeah I'm looking forward to carrying
more concoctions and demos in the future
awesome not sure if you're gonna be able
to do that with their short stubby arms
but I guess we'll find out please
comment like and subscribe below and if
you want to get in touch with us check
out the link in the description below
[Music]